- [Instructor] Riki Lindhome
and Kate Micucci, Micucci,
stars of HBO's Garfunkel and Oates,
are both a musical comedian.
Okay so we're talking about two people,
Riki Lindhome or Lindhome
and Katie Micucci.
We're talking about two people.
Then we say these two
people, Riki and Kate, are.
So, we agree with the
subject and the verb.
This is the plural form of is.
So are both, so you have two people are,
can two people both be a musical comedian?
This right over here
is one musical comedian
right over here, a musical comedian.
No, they're both, if we're
talking about both of them,
we're talking about that they
both are musical comedians.
So they are both musical comedians.
Get rid of the a and add an s at the end.
So this is that choice right over here.
So the key is, the subject,
we're talking about two people,
but then we're saying that
they are a musical comedian.
But no, they would be
both musical comedians.
You wanna have a plural right
over here, musical comedians.
So you definitely wanna change it.
And these other two choices are wrong
because these are both
singular, a comedian,
a comedian who plays music.
In either case, they're singular.
You want plural, musical comedians.